-Our first guest tonight is
a very talented actress you know
from films like "50 First
Dates," "Charlie's Angels,"
and "Never Been Kissed."
She now hosts
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
Please welcome back to the show
Drew Barrymore, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yay, Drew Barrymore, everybody!
Please!
-Hi, guys. How are you?
Thanks for having me.
-Drew, I'm so happy you're here.
-Me, too, because
I almost wasn't.
-Well, you were supposed to be
here a few weeks ago.
-Yes, I was.
-And it was a day-of
cancelation.
This is very rare.
-What happened?
Did someone else
fall off the wagon?
-No, when you canceled on us,
day-of.
-Not in 20 years have I canceled
on anyone, ever.
-Yes.
-I am very consistent.
-And yet here you were
very sick.
Not COVID,
but you were very sick.
-I had full-Blown bronchitis,
which I did not know
at the time.
And I've known you for so long
that I didn't want
a rep to call.
I feel like we're too knowing of
each other for that.
And I didn't want it to be like,
you know, surface.
So I decided to let you know
on my own terms
so that you felt it was true.
-So I didn't think you were
dodging or something came up.
You recorded an audio message
of yourself
to prove how sick you were.
[ Laughter ]
And it was like 45 seconds,
Drew,
and I could not make it
more than three.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. And I have to
admit, I was so sick that I
feel, like, a little bit
blackout-y about it.
Like, I was like, "I want to let
Seth know, with all my heart,
that something's really wrong."
-The thing is, you're also
a very good actress,
and this is so --
[ Laughter ]
No, no, but let me say this.
-Can you imagine if I faked it?
-If this was you acting,
I'd be like,
"Drew, this is so over-the-top."
[ Laughter ]
So we're gonna actually play it
so people can hear.
-Oh, my God!
-Because it is -- We're not
gonna play much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's audio only.
-Okay, I do not remember any of
this, except for that I was
like, "I have to tell Seth
and be personal about this."
What the -- Oh, God.
-This is like somebody in a very
bad dinner-theater production of
somebody who's like,
"Play a very sick person."
So let's listen.
-I have heard from every
director I've ever worked
with less.
-[ Gravelly voice ]
Hi, Seth, it's Drew.
I am --
[ Coughing ]
-Oh, my God!
-[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
I can't do your show because
I don't want to do that
on the show.
[ Laughter ]
-I realize now you're actually
doing E.T. which is really cool.
[ Laughter ]
-I totally am. I am E.T.
-It's a really good callback
to your early work.
-God, you never know what
you sound like.
-But that was very nice
that you did that.
I mean, especially now, because,
as a fellow talk-show host,
I think the host would be
the last person who would bail
at the last minute
unless they absolutely had to.
So I want you to know,
we totally understood.
-I mean, in some ways,
I kind of wish
I had brought that to the show.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It would have been
a pretty awesome vibe.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the thing where it's not
the right time to make jokes
about wellness.
-Nobody wants that.
Nobody wants that to come out
of the elevator.
-No, no. But I'm here now!
-I'm so happy to have you.
And not only are you
a talk-show host,
but you're a talk-show pro.
You started doing this
at a very young age.
-That's true.
-And we actually have a clip,
an incredibly precocious clip
of you on "Johnny Carson."
And I mean, you are --
Not only are you a kid,
but you are just so confident.
You're more confident than,
I would say,
half the adults I have
on this show.
-And we're both parents, so
we're around younger kids now.
-Yeah.
-Whereas, when I grew up, I was,
like, weirded out by kids
'cause I was, like, a working,
you know, paying-the-rent kid.
Didn't go to school,
I didn't have siblings.
I was always around adults.
So kids would be like,
"Mah mah mah!"
and I was like...
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "Do you behave
like that at your job?"
-Yeah, exactly.
-The kids were like,
"I don't have a job.
I'm seven."
-"Beat it, kid,
you're being a weirdo."
I just was -- I was, um --
I don't know how kids
are as precocious as they are
or how I was.
I feel like my life is
so full-circle in that
I'm much more intimidated
and dialed-back.
When you're a kid,
you don't know to filter.
-Yes.
-It's like Amy Schumer said
in that cute movie, "I Feel
Pretty," which I love so much.
She's like, "We let our bellies
hang out.
We don't think about it.
We say whatever we want."
We get older and more
conscientious of what people
think and feel,
and you start to almost
get shyer as you get older.
-Well, there was no shyness
here.
Let's show this clip real quick
of a young Drew.
-I love New York.
-Why?
-Well, I mean, it's my place.
I mean, I don't like to go --
I mean, I'm not a person,
really -- I mean, I love L.A.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, um, I like --
I don't like to dress up
in bikinis and go to the beach.
I like to dress up warm
and be in my thermies
and go run around the hotel.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, well, none of that
has changed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am the same person.
-I will say, the crazy thing
to me, is the awareness of
being in L.A. with an audience,
as you're doing a talk-show
appearance, and you're like,
"I love New York. I love L.A.,
too," that even as a kid,
you were like, "I don't want to
lose the audience here."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the first time I was
on "Carson," I walked up
to the stage and fell
and went, like, splat.
And that was a good moment
in that
it never can get worse
than that.
-Yes.
-You know?
You can't, like, eat it
in your first time out
on national television and not
go, "Well, you know what?
Only up from here."
[ Laughter ]
No fear and embarrassment
anymore.
-I have a lot of questions of
what you're doing
when you're not hosting
your talk show.
We're gonna be right back
with more
from Drew Barrymore, everybody.